حسب تصريحات وكاله او اداره الكوارث
والطوارئ التركيه فان عدد المباني التي
انهارت جراء هذا الزلزال الذي ضرب المنطقه
ظهر اليوم بلغ تسعه وعشرين مبنى جاري الان
او فرق الانقاذ والاغاثه تعمل على رفع
الانقاد بخمس مباني يعتقد ان ان يوجد
تحتها
عالقين لحد الان مقتل تم تسجيل مقتل شخص
واصابه تسعه وستين اخرين بجروح فيما تم
ايضا انقاذ شخصين من تحت الانقاض شاهدنا
قبل لحظات فيديوهات لاخراجهم بان تحت
الانقاذ هناك ايضا تم تسجيل 25 بلاغا من
المواطنين ولذلك تحركت فرق الانقاذ
والاغاثه للتابعه لمنظمه افاد اداره
الكوارث والطوارئ
التركيه هذا الزلزال الجديد قال عنه مدير
اداره افاد بانه
امر طبيعي يريد ان يهدئ نوعا ما المواطنين
ودعاهم للاستعداد لما هو ات من هزات وصفها
بانها ستكون قويه نوعا ما ستتجاوز الخمس
درجات على سلم ريختر وكانت هناك تحذيرات
للمواطنين بالابتعاد عن المباني تحسبا لاي
طارئ المكان الذي اتواجد فيه الان لا يبعد
عن الحدود السوريه التركيه الا باقل من
كيلومتر او كيلو مترين هناك حاله طوارئ
ايضا يعني في هذه البلده هناك اعمال جاريه
لتسويه ارضيه واسعه سيتم وضع فوقها مباني
جاهزه وشاليهات لاواء الاف المتضررين في
هذه البلده التي فقدت لوحدها حوالي 6000
قتيل اثراء الزلزال الذي ضرب المنطقه في
السادس من فبراير الماضي وايضا هناك
الالاف ممن اصبحوا بدون ماوى تجولنا في
هذه البلده ولم يعد هناك اي شخص في
المباني المتصدعه وهناك مخاوف من العوده
اليها